yeah we talk a lot about the modern
dating scene on this show and the
primary conclusion we've drawn is that
the modern dating scene is to put it
gently a disaster Zone a toxic waste
dump uh I don't want to be overly
negative or discouraging about it but it
is an unmitigated disaster it's a
radioactive meltdown it's the uh you
know sort of the dating equivalent of
Chernobyl and if that was not already
clear enough Tinder has according to an
article in New York Post released their
annual year in swipe report and this
tells us that uh this tells us about the
state of the date as they're calling it
according to one of the biggest and
worst dating apps in the world and the
results are pretty bleak so here's what
the report says quote young singles are
no longer doggedly pursuing their
happily ever after new data has revealed
according to tinder's annual year and
swipe which shares the state of the date
in 2023 singles are less concerned about
where their relationships are headed and
more interested in creating
opportunities to have new memorable
experiences this year in particular
marked a major shift where the journey
is more important than the outcome
Tinder Chief marketing officer Melissa
Hobley said quote this new generation of
daters is showing us what it means to
date for the possibilities freeing
themselves from traditional expectations
allowing them to write their own
worthwhile stories gen z uh Tinder
Australia spokesperson Christy Kirsty
Dunn agreed continue to Usher a
Renaissance in dating and this
generation is certainly straying away
from labels and the more traditional
expectations quote uh 69% of young
singles agree that dating standards need
refreshing to fit a more modern and
diverse Society now apparently this um
modern and diverse approach to dating
has a clever little acronym to go with
it and that acronym is NATO quote
tending military Buffs no it does not
stand for North Atlantic Treaty
Organization at least in the context of
Modern Love instead it's an acronym for
not attached to an outcome an approach
to dating that's been embraced by gen Z
this year and helps open up the
possibilities of any and all connections
instead of being fixated on a specific
endgame now quick side note it is yet
another sign of how low the bar has uh
has gone in society that you can call
yourself a military buff if you simply
know what NATO is but uh I digress
continuing users are not looking for
anything they're not pursuing uh they're
not putting pressures on themselves or
others by setting that expectation of
only looking for a relationship or only
looking for something casual she said
it's very much in line with what we've
been seeing over the last couple of
years particularly last year as
situationships become increasingly more
prevalent they're focused on getting to
know someone being in the present and
living in the moment they're leaving it
open-ended so that they can explore
whatever path they want which could be
quite freeing and
liberating now in other words apparently
now there are two different types of
NATO that need to be disbanded now
granted um you I never know with these
kinds of Articles whether they're just
inventing these buzzwords and acronyms
on the spot I find it somewhat hard to
believe that any actual 22-year-old
woman is out on a date saying you know I
take more of a NATO approach but whether
the acronym was invented by the media or
not the approach that it describes is
certainly very real and very common and
and very very wrong an open-ended
approach to dating where there's no end
goal or purpose or intention in mind is
a bad idea for much the same reason that
it's a bad idea to take the approach
like that to anything in life you know
platitudes about living in the moment
and being in the present um they may
seem appealing if you're kind of stupid
but intelligent people know that you
have to have some idea about where
you're going in each present moment and
why this is the case again no matter
what you happen to be doing even if
you're just taking a walk around the
neighborhood you need to know where
you're
going the difference between an
enjoyable stroll and getting horribly
lost and then ending up getting stabbed
in the chest when you wander down the
wrong back alley is simply knowing where
you're going that's the difference you
don't have to have every step planned
out you can and should be prepared to
change course if need be but you need to
have a direction a purpose a sense of
where you want to end
up going for a hike in the woods is fun
but if you're living in the moment the
entire time and keeping things
open-ended with no idea where you want
to go or where you should go or what
direction you ought to be heading then
it will become progressively less fun
until eventually you're completely lost
and you die alone of starvation and
hypothermia and that's basically how the
dating scene Works more or less are you
traveling for the holidays if so pure
talk has you covered because they just
added international roaming to over 30
countries that's right whether you're
calling uh making calls on a beach in
the Bahamas on the steps of Buckingham
Palace or at your Villa in sanini you
can dial away and here's the best part
there is no rate increase Pure Talk
still saves the average family uh almost
$1,000 a year with PL plan starting at
just $20 a month Pure Talk is the gift
that keeps on giving they put you on
America's Most Dependable 5G Network the
coverage is second to none stop dragging
your feet switch to Pure Talk a
veteran-owned Wireless company with
Simply the Best Us customer service team
around now with international roaming to
over 30 countries go to Pur talk.com
Walsh to make the switch you'll also
save an additional 50% off your first
month that's Pur talk.com Walsh to start
saving on wireless today Pure Talk
simply smarter Wireless the new stop byx
Pro is the leader in Rapid access
firearm security that does not use
batteries or Electronics if you're on
the fence about getting one you can now
get one for free the stopbox pro is the
latest evolution in Secure handgun
storage and is proudly made right here
in the USA building on the trusted
foundation of the original stopbox the
pro is larger more robust and even more
versatile but the Real Genius of the
stopbox pro lies in its patented hand
gesture code lock security doesn't mean
inconvenience that's the principle
behind the stopbox pro it's Sleek
portable and discreet ensuring your
firearm is safely stowed yet always
Within Reach whether you're at home or
on the go stopbox is offering a buy one
get one free deal on their new stopbox
Pro on top of that if you use the
discount code Matt a checkout you get an
additional 10% off so head on over to
stopbox usa.com right now click the link
below and ensure your Firearms are
secure and accessible when it matters
most that's stopbox usa.com for their
incredible discount of buy one get one
with an additional 10% off with code
Matt dating is not an exception to the
general principle that you should always
have a reason and a purpose behind your
actions um rather than just kind of
ambling around aimlessly and blindly you
know sort of bumping into things like
some sort of malfunctioning Roomba um
not only is dating not an exception to
that principle but it is if anything the
very best example of it because before
you venture wearily into the dating
scene you should be able to answer some
basic questions like one why am I doing
this two what do I hope to achieve three
where do I want this to
go and again those are questions you
should be able to answer no matter what
you happen to be doing in any given
moment and if you cannot answer any of
those questions about dating then you
just shouldn't be dating you probably
shouldn't even be driving like you are
so indecisive and apathetic as to barely
qu qu qualify as
sentient and if you wander out into the
dating world like that it's guaranteed
that either you'll end up feeling used
and manipulated and heartbroken or the
person you date will end up feeling that
way or most likely both of you will but
there is zero chance of a good outcome
that's the way life
works if you're vacillating too much to
pursue a specific out outcome then life
will pick an outcome for you and it
won't be one that you like because
there's going to be an outcome one way
or another you can either have one in
mind that you're chasing down or you
could just let chance to decide for you
and again usually when chance decides uh
it's not going to be in your
favor now as you've heard me preach many
times the proper outcome to pursue in
any dating relationship is marriage
that's what dating is for it's why it
exists dating is isn't something that we
should be doing simply for its own sake
that's because dating requires another
human being and that human being is a
human being not an object for you to use
recreationally and then
discard there's nothing really casual
about dating no matter what you might
try to tell
yourself it's always going to be the
leadup to something like it's a path
that ends somewhere and that place that
ends up will either be heartbreak or
marriage there's really no third option
and dating without the intent to marry
is dating with the intent to break
up that's the choice you make when you
venture out into the dating
scene like what are you looking for are
you looking for someone to marry or are
you looking for someone to break up with
which outcome would you prefer because
it's going to be one or the
other and only one is really worth
pursuing but you have to pursue
something which is why NATO dating if
that's what anyone actually calls it is
today cancelled if You' like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there godp speed